hey youtubers is Charlie doctor who eat
continues with my list of top 5 doctors
remember me and my friends have been
doing a bunch of special videos to
celebrate the 50th anniversary be sure
to subscribe to get everything we've got
some special stuff coming this weekend
including a live stream pre-show for the
50th anniversary episode and some other
stuff that I'll announce after I do my
list let's get started with number 5 the
fifth doctor Peter Davison so he had the
unfortunate task of following up one of
the most popular doctors in Doctor Who
history and in order to differentiate
himself from that he became this really
sweet and sensitive character his doctor
was also the first one to take a direct
stance against violence and would always
find these really creative solutions to
his problems
my favorite Peter Davison episode is the
caves of and Rossi it was his last
episode he knew he was dying and
basically just tried to make the most of
his last moments to try to make them
count as much as he could consequently
io9 also rated that episode the best
Doctor Who story of all time so you
should definitely check it out before
the 50th anniversary number for Matt
Smith the eleventh Doctor so just like
Peter Davison Matt Smith had to follow
up one of the most popular doctors in
Doctor Who history which is really hard
to do but he totally won me over with
this boundless enthusiasm all of time
and space where do you want to go he was
also my introduction to the series so he
has a special place in my heart
Steven Moffat also became showrunner at
the same time Matt Smith became the new
doctor so they introduced a lot of new
aspects to Doctor Who's story that we
hadn't seen before namely what's
happening now in the 50th anniversary
episode John her doctor the warrior
doctor my favorite Matt Smith episode is
definitely the doctor's wife because he
ended up marrying River Song but he
married the TARDIS first or maybe the
TARDIS married him first it depends on
how you look at it number three
Christopher Eccleston the Ninth Doctor
so he is famous for regenerating Doctor
Who in this really new and interesting
way with Russell T Davies so his doctor
was this post-traumatic stress survivor
of the time war who had to live with the
guilt of having trapped his entire race
in this inescapable time loop despite
the mental scarring that the time war
left on the doctor
Eccleston really had this adventurous
side to him that was a lot of fun of all
the doctors Eccleston is also the most
physically imposing so remember the
doctor is supposed to be the most
fearsome man in the universe in order to
do that you have to be able to convey
this intensity without even speaking and
Eccleston did that very
very well he could make you
uncomfortable just by standing next to
you he's a very big man
my favorite Christopher Eccleston
episode is rose because that is the one
that regenerated Doctor Who that is the
one that started it all number two Tom
Baker the fourth doctor so number four
had the benefit of being on the show
during the height of his popularity and
because of that popularity his scarf is
one of the most recognizable pieces of
Doctor Who's clothing Baker's doctor had
this really funny goofy sense about him
that really made you feel like he was
taking himself much less seriously than
he was during the third incarnation when
he was this kind of Action Hero II type
person the great part though is that it
did not shift too far into parody so he
definitely made you believe like he was
this really wise alien despite the fact
that he was so goofy although Matt
Smith's really physically comedic take
on the doctor is unique to him I feel
like he was inspired just a little bit
by the goofiness of Tom Baker Baker's
run on Doctor Who is also characterized
by some of the best writers and best
stories that Doctor Who ever had so his
take on the doctor and the amazing
stories that they were writing at the
time works so well together that it
really helped push Doctor Who to this
new level of international fame my
favorite Tom Baker episode is city of
death for a couple reasons
so one Douglas Adams wrote the script
under the name David Agnew which in and
of itself became a Doctor Who legend
it's also one of the greatest epic
stories from classic Doctor Who where
style and story and actors all come
together in the best possible way and my
number one doctor David Tennant number
10 so I feel like so many things changed
during David Tennant's run for the
better so many things about Doctor Who
as well as the character that he
definitely deserves this spot on the
list just to give you an idea how he
affected Doctor Who popularity
internationally so the BBC basically had
to change the way they air the show
because so many people were downloading
in international countries international
piracy got so bad that the BBC had to
shorten the window time when they air
the episode so that everyone else could
watch them sooner the very same thing
that they're doing with the 50th
anniversary episode this Saturday so to
combat piracy
they're basically airing it in every
single country at the exact same moment
that's why it's a different time at
every time zone so Tennant had this
amazing commitment to the role that
allowed him to go from this really kind
of light-hearted carefree sweet doctor
to just crazy intense he's like fire and
ice and rage that came from Tennant my
favorite David Tennant episode is blink
because weeping angels which also
having to be my favorite villain but the
core concept of the episode a stone
statue can get you when you're not
looking at it it's just so creepy and
the idea that the doctor left Clues for
a girl using DVD bonus features it's
just so clever Steven Moffat actually
won two awards for the script on that
episode with that in mind you should all
buy the DVD for the 50th anniversary
unless you won one in my contest and
watch all of the bonus features all of
them but since everyone experiences
Doctor Who in their own unique way right
below in the comments what your top 5
doctors are so tomorrow I'll be posting
my review of an adventure in space and
time be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll also be announcing the winners of
my DVD contest I'll be giving away 5
copies of the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary episode also be sure to post
details on the other bonus videos that
are going to be coming this weekend
because there's a lot of extra stuff I'm
also going to be on the BBC pre-show for
the 50th anniversary as well as the
BBC's channel on Sunday I'll post more
details about that in another video this
weekend also remember that pre-show
livestream will be happening at 2:30
p.m. Pacific Time on Saturday that'll be
on the BBC America's YouTube channel
I'll post the link to it in the
description as soon as they post that
video too though be sure to watch it
because my face will be there
it'll be tons of fun right now click on
one of these annotations to see the
awesome videos that my friends are doing
for Doctor Who week thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives